so we have our first sound bite from
tonight from a town hall where joe biden
is
in philadelphia and he is talking
tonight about
mask mandates let's listen to this
that if in fact we wore masks we could
say between now and the end of the year
a hundred
thousand lies and avoid lockdowns and
avoid lockdown yes
you don't have to lock down if you're
wearing the mask let's get a question
okay you heard him there so he says
masked mandates
he tells george stephanopoulos they will
not have to lock down
if you allow people to wear masks which
i don't know where that that is coming
from that's
a whole new statement that i've never
heard before
um but i want to read you something else
this is something else he said that was
not
part of what we played he says that how
would you enforce a masked
mandate because biden wants a masked
mandate across the country now please
keep in mind panel
if joe biden becomes president he does
not take office
until late january of 2021
so any mass mandate that would be
instituted would then be instituted
across the country
beginning what in february of 2021 and
then running for however long
but this is what he says how would you
enforce that how would you make that
happen he says i would go to every mayor
i would go to every councilman
i would go to every local official and
say mandate
the mask apparently so that you don't
have to lock down anymore that's
what he's now saying so first of all how
do you think voters will respond to
this idea i mean just the idea of
permanent masking at least for the
foreseeable next what
year two years how long are we talking
here gary we're gonna have to wear masks
forever is that is that what the biden
campaign promises